hey guys back in Roseanne's
kitchen-table what are we doing it rose
ants kitchen-table bear is a annotation
right here you can find out or there is
a link down below and I am with one of
my favorite people and Ruben report
casts Cara Santa Maria all day oh okay
and one of the reasons that I love
having Cara on the show is that I screw
up a lot of science things science was
never my thing I was more of like
English social studies kind of guy I
screw up a lot of science and math stuff
and you often come on the show and you
clean up the mess that I made and that
is that is the job of scientists right
to clean up the mess that the laymen
make I get I get love sometimes in the
comments yeah you would get a lot of
good Dave in his place
yes so you do a great job with that so I
wanted to talk to you today about this
vaccination situation because over the
last couple years it's been a big thing
with people not getting kids vaccinated
it's and a movement we're gonna show a
graph just to show you how much it's
been growing in California we're gonna
show you that in just a sec but now
there's been an outbreak of measles that
apparently started at Disneyland here in
California so I wanted to just sort of
get your feelings on vaccinations on
this outbreak on the parental
responsibility the science behind it cuz
that's what no but everyone just talks
about the the scariness of it sort of
like Ebola which you cleaned up for us
last time
but wait did you make a mess yet with
vaccines make a mistake should I make a
mess first well how about what let's
start with this I'm gonna show you take
a look at this this is a map and you can
see in this map how over the last couple
years that the amount of parents that
have chosen to opt out of getting their
kids vaccinated for measles has
increased in California so these are
parents that use the personal belief
exemption to get their kids not
vaccinated so they didn't have to take
vaccinations that was that that was all
that was pretty good those red clusters
there that you see are more than five
percent of the population and those are
just verbal claims people who have
actually said on paperwork that they are
taking that personal belief exemption a
lot less people get vaccinated even even
than that right okay so let's start for
again for like just a layman basic
people I know nothing about science
people don't want measles right no you
don't don't you don't want me so so
they vaccinated us for measles you've
been vaccinated for measles right I've
been vaccinated remember you got it was
called the MMR vaccine probably the
measles mumps and rubella vaccine and
these sound like Victorian diseases
don't think rubella who do you know that
fella
right exactly same thing with measles I
mean it was all been eradicated really
in America the same way we think of
polio as having been eradicated we were
very close to eradicating measles and
now we're seeing it creep back into the
population right okay so that sounds
crazy that it's coming back so why would
people not want to have their kids
vaccine well this is a complicated issue
and I think it's easy sometimes as a
science communicator as an advocate for
improving science literacy and also as
somebody who's liberal i commonly throw
the right-wingers under the bus when it
comes to anti science you know we throw
the right-wingers under the bus when it
comes to climate change denial and when
it comes to denying evolution and then
we like to kind of play both sides and
say yeah but you know the the left
they're really anti science and they're
way too with the woowoo medicine and the
anti-vaxxer but the truth is the
anti-vaxxer than that so you do have
different sects of people who are
against vaccinations for different
reasons you for sure have the lefty
Hollywood types the Jenny McCarthy
followers who think that there's a link
between vaccines and autism based on
debunked research from Andrew Wakefield
forever ago in The Lancet that just
years and years and years of evidence
has shown that there is no link yet that
still perpetrates yeah she still
believes in perhaps right I guess I
think she's kind of a little bit she's
if she's evolved a little bit but there
is actually a website I can't remember
exactly what the URL is I'm sure
somebody will throw it up in the
comments something like Jenny McCarthy
body-count calm that's actually yeah
it's horrible it's actually calculated
the number of people that because of the
damage that she's done publicly telling
people not to vaccinate their children
the number of deaths that have come from
that well all right all right well we're
gonna try to find that side and we'll
put that yeah
in the link but here so we're talking
about yes we're talking about liberal
kind of little new agey hippie with
money and you do notice that you have
these clusters of anti VAX rhetoric in
Orange County versus Los Angeles for
exam if you're going to dissect
California you do actually see in
wealthier communities but then again you
also have more conservatives in Orange
County and you also have more religious
exemptions that are taking place there
so it's kind of on both sides of the
aisle right so okay so the religious
exemptions I get if it's somehow in your
religious doctrine I don't understand it
person yeah it's not how I would do it
but I can understand so let's just
remove those people in the equation
because they probably have always
existed but we do need to but we do need
to reinforce that those people are part
of the problem and that sometimes like
we don't have to talk about them now but
let's not forget that they exist and
let's not forget that they are
contributing to this problem
right so not yeah I don't want to remove
them altogether but for the purposes of
this those types of people and people
who do things for religious reasons
obviously have always existed so what
what's with the new wave this this
Hollywood thing this rich people you
would think rich people more educated
right but is there like what's the fear
like what's the fear part what do they
think is happening because of the
vaccinations I think that's like the
real question yeah you know I think that
there's this modern kind of distrust of
medicine that started to take place
where people are more interested in
naturopathy homeopathy they're
interested in kind of this what we call
woo-woo medicine which is not
evidence-based that might be more
Eastern influenced and holistic and and
and there's a real fear of Big Pharma
yeah and there's a real fear of vaccines
as they've been linked to big pharma and
I mean it's pretty easy to point to the
original place where that came and that
is that Wakefield study that was
published in The Lancet many years ago
and there's a great book on the topic
called the panic virus by Seth manikin I
definitely recommend reading that
because he really digs into the fact and
this is an important fact that a rumor
or misinformation even if people at the
time think that it's correct is so much
easier to spread through a population
then the correction that comes out way
like somebody makes a claim and it goes
and people go oh god is that true is
that true oh that's true is published in
a medical journal
if months later you say okay wait a
minute we retracted that from the
journal it's not true here's the
correction that doesn't spread through
the population somehow don't spray yeah
so that's a huge problem and then let's
be honest there are people who struggle
with early childhood illnesses there are
people who have children with autism and
they are distraught and they want
answers and when they see an ostensible
link which again let's be clear has been
debunked you can't blame them for
grasping at those straws because they
really want to know what's going on but
the truth is it's not the thimerosal in
the vaccines most vaccines don't have
thimerosal thimerosal was removed from
the vaccines and vaccines do so much
more hot or do so much more good than
harm oh my god right well they do so
much more good than harm it's it's
apples and oranges really to try and
compare the good versus the harm yeah
and the real issue comes in it's that
there are children out there who have
let's say an allergy to egg albumin
that's a component of vaccines there are
children out there who have compromised
immune systems for example that can't
take vaccines they're medically
incapable of taking vaccines and if you
decide not to vaccinate your child
because you have some non scientifically
based kind of spiritual or Jenny
McCarthy following reason for it you're
putting that other person's child at
risk and that's what happened to
Disneyland they've now linked close to
70 measles cases to one person with
measles and going to Disneyland and the
truces that shouldn't happen
there should be herd immunity there
should be enough people present that are
vaccinated that you're not going to get
sick so what do they do to the kids once
they have measles now can you get the
vaccination once you have it man just
disappears no that's not how vaccines
work vaccines are prophylactic you know
vaccines aren't treatments if that was
they stopped they stopped it or they're
killing it they started killing it
before it what's the scientific town
they're not even killing it here's what
happened most vaccines the way that they
is that their inactivated virus so
basically they inject the enough the
inactivated virus or something that
looks a lot like the virus into your
bloodstream or into your muscle or you
know wherever and your body produces
antibodies against that virus
so you mildly think that you've caught a
case of it you produce these antibodies
and now if you're ever exposed to it
again in small quantities your body can
fight it off before you ever get so the
kid so the kids that get it now how do
they fight it then is that the question
I mean is there really that's you know
if they've got a weakened immune system
there's a risk of death I mean they're
going to be able to get treatment
obviously but think about the fact that
for example somebody who is HIV positive
they oftentimes yes we can say that the
cause of death eventually might be AIDS
but more often it's something like
pneumonia it's something that a normal
immune system can fight off and it's a
very similar thing with with these other
different types of viral infections if
you're very young or very old you may
not be equipped to fight off something
like measles if you're relatively
healthy and you have access to good
medication your body might be able to
eventually fight it off and then you'll
have this this immunity that you've
developed because you caught it yourself
say chickenpox none of us were
vaccinated against chicken right we got
it we caught it we fought it off and we
couldn't catch it again because now we
were immune to it right that's how the
flu vaccine works the idea is that if
you take it each year it's a slightly
different variation you're developing
immunity for years and years and years
to other strains of influenza right the
problem is there are certain diseases
that are highly virulent measles if
you're not vaccinated you have a 90%
chance of catching it if you are exposed
to it and I'm talking like somebody
sneezes in the same room as you think
about Disneyland somebody sneezes on a
rail somebody go to the bathroom right
after somebody that you're probably
gonna catch it if you're not vaccinate
yeah and those kids that are touching
all this stuff super gross anyway we
obviously could go that I think is the
major take it is really what we also get
vaccinated for stuff anyway there
there's so much here but I think I hope
we gave you just kind of a little bit to
work with clearly you're on the side of
getting back
my science lady as you should be - says
get vaccinated what do you guys think
what do you believe in the science
behind this do you believe in something
else are you taking the religious
exemption let us know in the comments
right down below